قال الرئيس الاوكراني
بلاده على استعداد لسلام عادل ونزيه وفق
شروط باتت معلومه للعالم واضاف من بين
الشروط محاسبه روسيا وتعويض اوكرانيا عن
الخسائر التي لحقت بها
نحن جاهزون للسلام لكن لسلام عادل ونزيه
وقد تحدثنا مرارا عن شروطه والعالم يعرف
موقفنا وهو احترام ميثاق الامم المتحده
واحترام وسلامه اراضينا واحترام مواطنين
وتحميل المسؤوليه للارهابيين عن افعالهم
ومعاقبه المذنبين وتعويض روسيا لنا عن كل
الخسائر والاطراف
ان الولايات المتحده وتشيك وهولندا وفرت
90 دبابه من طراز في 72 لبلاده ووصف هذه
المساعدات العسكريه بالدعم الكبير
والمطلوب بشده وان القوات الاوكرانيه
تتقدم وتحتاج الى هذه المعدات وعرب عن
شكريه لتلك الدول